[Music]
[Music]
hello humans and also dom yeah and you
we're back aren't we oh yeah we are done
well back for another week
and this is going to feature the second
part of what i would coin a fascinating
interview with our friend mark ordesky
mark odesky what a fascinating and
wonderful guy he
was so instrumental in bringing together
the lord of the rings trilogy and he's
not one of the more kind of
out there known names as he obviously
you've got pete and fran and philip and
you of course
but mark odesky uh did a lot of
string pulling yeah i think he's quite
happy to be
you know sort of
in the background but he was as you say
absolutely instrumental in getting those
movies made
so coming up is the second part of our
fascinating interview with marco but
we're gonna do a little bit before then
some housekeeping
much fun are you
to keep your house so clean and chill
peeling the onion
oh well done dom that was lovely you
want to do this first one yes absolutely
first off i freak this is from christian
k from seattle seattle sierra
that's in washington
not washington dc no washington state
which is just underneath
vancouver right
washington state washington d.c
first off washington state
that's where seattle is is that right
this is florida
california yeah i'm gonna say is it kind
of go to your wedding finger to the tip
of your wedding finger and then just
come yeah i would say there johnny clues
washington state washington
[Applause]
washington dc
no idea but i'm going to say the center
of your hand
is that this johnny club is that the
center of your hand
washington dc
i also say sorry i should probably
correct it the seattle was like a finger
below
well that was very good you get one
washington right yeah when we go for
christian uk who's in seattle washington
near my uh wedding finger
first off i phrased your names in that
order
because i feel like everyone always says
billy and dom and i want you to let dom
it be first ones lovely
and uh john's not put however no he
hasn't so he's omitted she's a shame
john
second
it's a fundamental element of the
message well i think what's with their
names is billy and dom blah blah blah
billy and don that works but dom monahan
and billy boyd i think works better
because i've always said to you over the
years whenever we're doing something
together i've always said it should be
billy and dom it shouldn't be dom and
billy i think billion dumb just rolls
off the tongue a little bit better but i
think don monahan and billy boyd runs
better than billy boyd and don monaghan
yeah you might be right there lovely i'm
glad we sorted that job great
observation second potato scones
regarding your potato scones recipe
which is one of the greatest in the
world
triangles don't waste more dough than
squares because any square can be turned
into two triangles just cut it
diagonally
and it's just the same so you can keep
the traditional triangles with the peace
of mind that you're maximizing doe usage
thanks for doing the show you guys rock
here's why my sister's oh geez knocked
him right now
there yeah i didn't i knocked my cans
off uh my sister says that the reason
the triangles
they're weapons so you can fit them in
the frying pan
in a sort of circle
see if you put all the triangles
together like a pizza
then it makes a sort of circle right and
then it sits in the frying pan without
wasting any frying pan space great yeah
i'll go for that i'll go for that and oh
well done margaret thank you and thank
you christian k now another uh message
here from zane a right
regarding billy's knee right um zaine
didn't say where they're from right
from austin oh from austin austin texas
oh yeah yeah
uh zane said hello i just discovered
your podcast and i'm pretty early in the
episodes okay but if billy's knee is
still so i have a quick suggestion that
might be helpful you may have heard of
zero shoes no i haven't okay apparently
normal shoes weaken the foot and the
incline in the sole can lead to a strain
on the body's joints knees included they
work for my knee pain but it did take a
while to adapt hopefully that can help
or preferably billy is better now thanks
for this treasure of a podcast i'm
enjoying it especially dom oh thanks
thank you for that zayn i might try
those um i think uh me falling off a
motorbike when i was 16 really affected
money
rossi
boston italy no ross is a little island
off of the west coast of scotland oh wow
yeah were you going fast yeah
so talk us through that did the bike
fall underneath your knee or something
so i was there with my friends it was
one of the first holidays that we all
had together 16 years old oh debauchery
stupidly the guy at the motorbike store
rented us motorbikes
and i was i was dashing around for a
couple of days loving it so loving it
loving the freedom dom i wore a helmet
don't you worry about that but i was
coming down to a junction and a car
swooped out in front of me
and
and i put i put on the anchors
i put on the brakes there
and the back wheel went i can imagine it
now yeah i can see that but was gone
like that yeah and i put my leg down it
kind of stopped myself and the motorbike
sort of hit it and then i just ended up
on the ground
and then and my knee was really slow
and they took me to the hospital in
rossi
and uh
i remember phoning my sister
and i says okay i can't come we're
supposed to go home the next day can't
go home i'm in the hospital she says i
bet you're not i bet you don't want to
go to work yeah yeah but you're out
drinking with your amazing gallivanting
galavant all over rossi but i was
thinking i've been injured i've been
significantly injured this might this
might affect the rest of my life yeah
and well i tore the ligament and i got
all the
cartilage taken out and then and there
was about six months of physiotherapy
and i couldn't play football anymore oh
really because i remember
you and i
would take a drive quite often actually
we probably did it over 10 times in new
zealand in wellington to a place called
castle point yeah you drive
kind of up a mountain yeah yeah you come
down the other side of the mountain it's
about an hour and change drive
uh to get to castle point to go surfing
with our mates and i was behind you at
one point and you were giving it this in
your mirror we didn't have mobile phones
at that point you're giving it this in
your mirror pointing like that i didn't
know what you were doing but you were
basically saying come on let's take a
look i'm saying we got to the top of the
hill
uh and i remember thinking he's running
out of petrol and i went over and said
what's going on and you said i don't
think i can drive anymore because my
knee is locking and it's excruciatingly
painful
it's it's been with me my whole
lifestyle i get years and years of it
being okay and then something will move
and then oh something will happen
do you remember once we we were running
a petrol because i don't know if you
remember but we had we had cards for
petrol in new zealand that we could use
yeah that the studio played for paid for
of course they didn't but it wasn't a
lot of these petrol stations they were
just in certain places
and your friend tom was over visiting
you and he was in the car with us and
we'd almost let the petrol run out we're
like going over that hill going oh no
and he's like why didn't you put in like
five dollars before you give her we're
like no because we get it free with this
car then we can just make it to that
garage
cheap which is very cheap now there's
another one here about misheard lyrics
you want to read this yeah you ready tom
from joe from the forest of dean i don't
know where the first thing is for it's a
great name for a place i mean i've heard
of it about i don't know where it is
anyway
my wife is a one direction fan and when
our daughter was little we used to
listen to them in the car
they have a song called perfect that has
this lyric dom
if you like causing trouble up in hotel
rooms and if you like having secret
little rendezvous
right but i get into the habit of
singing runny poos
instead of rendezvous
my daughter loved it but my wife
hated it
most most wives will
hate runny poos because they're usually
um
the person that has to clean them up
if you like causing trouble up in hotel
rooms and if you like having secret
little poos running poos
you change the lyric again
how ironic um
um
i've always said we're not there yet but
i've always said there was a certain
amount of subscribers or listeners where
i would tell the story where i
accidentally shat myself at work but i
don't know 300 thousand minutes is that
right i don't think we're there yet well
we at johnny clues
on youtube now not yet we're not there
yet don't don't say it nearing a hundred
and twenty three thousand dollars
but guys subscribe i'm sure you are if
you're listening or watching but tell
your friends tell your friends hey guys
subscribe because if we get 200 000 um
listeners don monaghan's going to tell
us the time that he um
lost control of his bowels while he's
wearing shorts at work
fell into my sandals it's a fantastic
story and there is sandals involved yeah
now the last bit of uh correspondent oh
not the last i see but a piece of
correspondence here about a misheard
lyric from sean fitzsimmons via youtube
who said my five-year-old thinks the end
of smells like team spirit by nirvana is
kurt cobain yelling a potato over and
over again
a potato
yeah
yeah i could see that hey what a video
put them in the pot mashems spud them i
can't remember that line it was sean
aston's yeah the video is um they
nirvana start playing at a kind of
school sports hall and it all looks
relatively civilized at the start and
then by the end of it
the lights have gone down everyone's
moshing around the cheerleaders have
gone nuts it starts off as like uh
take your time
help me baby one more time oh britney
brent it looks like britney spears but
it doesn't end little britney no it ends
like a sex pistols video yeah um okay
another piece of correspondence william
anne from maine
says hello
did you all name your swords on set what
were they called i thought of this
because arrogance for sword name isn't
mentioned and then i wondered about
everyone else's as well thank you i love
the podcast
did you name your sword
does mary's sword have a name in the
book i don't think it does
it's not noble swords it's just
someone's dagger isn't it that we've got
yeah given to us by strider at the time
yeah yeah in aragon
asked his sword called the little prick
no was it not eh i thought
i might have been remembering it wrong
um no so just elijah's which is called
sting
not to be confused with the lead singer
of the police no because he doesn't glow
blue when orcs are nearby not as far as
we know no but though that sword did
what's the name of aragorn sword uh
brian yeah
uh gandalf has a sword name right is it
clandering
something like that your tongue's coming
out more than the words are saying i'm
thinking about tongue twisters
uh please send your tongue twisters
because it's one of my favorite parts of
the show listening to billy adopt an rp
accent to her tongue twister
um and then we've got one final message
here from
derek
loptech
who says i teach middle school english
seventh and eighth grade
i've heard there is such a thing as
imposter syndrome where
some people think
some people feel like they have bitten
off more than they can chew
you two were stars in the greatest film
trilogy ever arguably in brackets and i
wonder how you approached it day in and
day out how did you adjust yourself to
project confidence and get the
impossible job done what advice would
you give to those who struggle with
imposters syndrome asking for a friend
not sure what what is imposter syndrome
do you yeah it's a very famous uh
syndrome how famous i've never heard of
it where people
um don't feel like they deserve
what's happening to them oh i do
you don't i absolutely do
free stuff free pizzas
cash i'm like yeah yeah i deserve that
yeah do you feel no sometimes i feel a
little bit it's i mean i think it's like
you know
it's a sort of working class chip on
your shoulder isn't it it's a little bit
sore i remember reading to
famous actors i think it was bart
reynolds and [ __ ] eastwood
and bert reynolds was having panic
attacks oh no
and he said to clint eastwood i just
can't sometimes i can't get my breath
and i don't and he says look they're
lucky
you deserve this everything that's
happening to you you deserve it don't
ever feel any different and that was he
obviously knew about impostor syndrome
right and i think but reynolds just felt
this has all happened too fast dad and
there's better actors than me and
there's and
he he had that so
just enjoy it just enjoy yourself that's
what dom says enjoy it never felt a bit
of that never well actually thinking
about it now when you when you explain
what it was there was one time
where the four hobbits
were approached by apple do you remember
this yeah
this was when
fellowship had come out or where
i think it was fellowship fellowship had
come out we were lucky enough to be in
what was at that point the biggest film
on the planet no question and apple
approached the four hobbits and they
said if in new york if you are willing
to take a photo
outside the apple store
you can go basically on a
apple supermarket sweep yeah and we got
ipods
laptops cameras video cameras
i mean sean astin almost left with the
furniture in there it was it was an
amazing time and
what a great memory and they took a
photo and we got all these computer
things and
but i remember afterwards my lovely
agent in london aud powell
says just give me a call when something
like that happens with you because we'd
probably have made about
50 times more if it had been an official
fight yeah we probably would have they
saw enough they saw an opportunity
so we thought we did great with that
yeah we've got free stuff
and your agents by saying well you could
have got free stuff and a lot of cash at
the same time and i could have get 10 of
the cash oh yeah of course but it was an
amazing moment but i do remember sitting
in my hotel room and thinking wait a
second so
just because i'm in these films they're
going to give us all of this stuff so
that's a mini imposter syndrome but it
doesn't happen often usually i think
absolutely that's mine but that's as if
someone else said that don't they like
when you're when you're not working in
your skin and you're trying to make the
rent you can't get anything and then
when you've done a job and you've got
about money in your pocket that's when
people want to give you free stuff
it's weird isn't it because leonardo
dicaprio fantastic actor i love all the
work that he does brilliant seems to be
a fantastic guy loves his conservation
does all the right things yeah i mean
leonardo dicaprio probably can just call
any company out there and say fancy
sending me your stuff and they'd say
yeah we'll do that you want a free car
yeah you want to stay at this hotel yeah
and he's
he can afford yeah to pay for it
these car companies should give it to
other people
just give them cars
people don't always realize that
physical symptoms like headaches teeth
grinding and even digestive issues can
be indicators of stress and let's not
forget about doom scrolling sleeping too
little sleeping too much under eating
and overeating now billy you and i have
very busy lives we're racing around all
the time
we also have a podcast to do yeah it can
be stressful maybe we need a little bit
of better help stress shows up in all
kinds of ways and then a world that's
telling you to always do more sleep less
grind all the time here's your reminder
to take care of yourself do less and
maybe try some therapy
bet help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy give
it a try and see if online therapy can
help lower your stress this podcast is
sponsored by better help and the
friendship onion listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
onion that's b e t t e r h e l p dot com
slash onion
hey billy what i'm taking a flight soon
yep i'm going through an airport and one
of the things that i like to make sure
that i have ready to go is my expressvpn
account because using the internet
without expressvpn is like taking a call
on a train or a bus on speaker for
everyone to hear
you don't know who has access to your
most private sensitive information so
don't be that person and in the us they
can legally sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who then use
your data to target you terrible i know
anyway expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that people can't peep
on your online activity just fire up the
app and click one button it works on
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi can be protected
no wonder it's rated number one by
business insider and the verge secure
your online activity today at
expressvpn.com
onion and get an extra three months of
expressvpn
free that's expressvpn.com
onion expressvpn.com
onion
well what are we doing no dumb well
should we bring on marco for the second
oh that's a great idea because um
he's a fascinating guest and a great
friend and i think you guys will really
enjoy listening to him talk about what
his life was like when he was making the
lord of the rings trilogy
i was going to ask you mark maybe maybe
you can't answer this or maybe enough
times gone by where you can
for you during the filming process yeah
what was the biggest problem that you
had to try and solve
during the filming process yeah well you
woke up and thought this is the one this
is the doozy
gosh i wish something would come to mind
quickly
[Music]
what about the stew incident you're
around for the yeah unfortunate yes i
was recasting events i was around for
for the stuart incident and i probably
and i was probably more
involved in that than i might have been
otherwise
um yeah so you know we cast stewart
townsend to be aragorn um who is someone
that that that peter felt very strongly
about
and
and all you all guys went down everyone
went down early yeah right with pete
with stu for what at least six weeks or
so before maybe even more yeah for you
know horse training sword training
whatever whatever's going on and
and i remember and so stuart went down
and part of that process and the one
one
note that the studio had which i would
have communicated is like because
stewart is like is quite slim and you
know he's he's athletic yeah but he was
and we so we thought well maybe as part
of his process you know
you know
they'll be you know they'll be training
apart from horses and everything else
he's going to do you know that sort of
thing and i think that inadvertently
when you when you do those kinds of
things
i think looking back on it
it can create
it can create insecurity or it can
create not an ideal environment for
people
i'm completely guessing right um
so
when ultimately the decision was made to
go a different way
i remember thinking that like you know
it's you know obviously they had their
own process you know peter and stewart
about what you know what was a fit what
wasn't a fit but yeah that was hard i
was in a hotel room in london
when that decision got made and i got
woken up at two in the morning
by barry
you know and um and yeah we had to move
very quickly
to to make that change i remember i
wrote down
three or four names on a hotel pad
i wrote down um vigo russell crowe and
jason patrick
at the time
those are the names that i wrote down
those are the names i wrote down at the
time and then of course by the time i
got a hold of peter and fran they'd
already written they were already had
vigo on their list of that well there
you go then
um so that's how that tended to happen
so that's certainly kind of a standout
problem um
but in terms of the amount of units that
the trilogy had going at any given point
in different parts of new zealand
different call times different actors so
many different
crew members
is it overwhelming for you to to be
aware of the fact that this is such a
huge operation or do you treat it like
pete was doing which is a massive
independent film i treated it the way
pete did and also we were very fortunate
i mean each unit apart from barry
osborne we had these robust production
managers for every unit as you guys know
and robust ads so it really was an
unbelievably great team so i tried i
remember tried never to think about the
fact that we had seven units going if
you include like miniature unit and blue
screen unit and sort of gollum unit you
know like that i tried never to think
about it too much but then when we would
watch dailies if you guys ever did that
and of course it was on film yeah so no
there's no fast forwarding there's no
anything you watch and that could that
could that took two three hours could
you believe that pete did that yeah
always filming and then sitting watching
sometimes
twenty takes of the same thing watching
everything i could i would go once every
year we would go every couple of weeks
yeah yeah we'd go and it was billy's
class come on you've got to come down oh
let's see some magic
i remember philippa telling me that i
remember philip was saying because i met
i made mention of that you know pete
goes to dailies every night and peace
then phil said
well pete's up at you know 4 35 in the
morning talking to l.a talking to new
york then he does a full day's work then
he goes and watches two three sometimes
four hours of dailies then he goes home
then between him and fran and phil they
make sure that they know what's going on
tomorrow talks to you right talks to
barry talks to zane then gets back on
the phone with la and new york you know
phil was saying you know pete might be
lucky enough to get five six hours sleep
at night if he's lucky yeah the great
thing about p
was any time because there were times
where obviously pete looked exhausted
and you know that i mean he's still a
little bit like this now but i i
remember his hair grew out very long and
he was never cleaning these glasses and
walking around barefoot and there were
times where i'd say are you okay p you
know
you know obviously looking a bit tired
and pete would always be like
there's nowhere else i'd rather be yeah
that's true i'm here making this
incredible film in my own country having
a great time you know so again it all
trickles down from
the top right no one can complain if the
leader is got that level of stamina and
focus and by the way all those dailies
when we were in edit he would remember
like there's a take
where billy does a thing
with his hand and i really i think
that's the one and sure enough
you know
there would be the thing i'm like how
did you know i was gonna mention that
yeah that's gonna mention i had the same
experience i was in dalys one time it's
just me i think i was waiting for one of
your close-ups and um
and there was a there was a there was a
sequence that they seemed to i don't
think they ever used in the trilogy
which was slightly god's view of
orlando gimli sorry not orlando legolas
gimli and aragorn on horseback going
through a kind of
mountainous path slightly slightly
bird's eye view so you're kind of seeing
the the top of these guys just snaking
through
a path
pete had a little one of those little
laser pointers and we were watching you
know take two or take three and piece
pete said the same thing that you said
you said oh wait hang on a second guys
there's a shot that's a little lower and
it's a little bit more kind of hero
arrogant let's fast forward through all
this stuff and get to that shot i was
like how does he know he's just spent
all day on set doing something else yeah
i mean he he is a he is a brilliant mind
pete um but mike that goes the full
circle back to your original question
about like the most important thing is
for people wanting to be in the business
is finding these kinds of collaborators
to work with because one thing that
newline had going for that no one else
you know there were people in hollywood
that didn't even take the meeting
on lord of the rings no judgment that
just
happened yeah but but
but because we knew him
as a person not just oh he wrote a great
nightmare on elm street script or oh
we liked having the creatures you know
that anyone can know that but you knew
him as a person of terms of character
stamina you know integrity
someone that's not just gonna like
give up when the going gets tough like
you know that would never happen never
ever yeah yeah yeah he's just not that
guy is he
um yes i'd like to get your side of this
smart because um obviously it was a
different
um experience for all of us when we got
to the cannes film festival yeah and as
a producer
what lauda rings did at the cannes film
festival as someone who's not a producer
seemed really ballsy yeah and kind of
in some ways old-fashioned or something
like old hollywood
and i'd love to get um
story that you have of how that happened
and for people who don't know lord of
rings did a big thing it can i mean
before the first yeah very big they had
sets over there uh brought a lot of the
actors over we showed about 26 minutes
of the film
yeah so it was it was just getting
through the kind of watcher it was more
yeah bookended with with really robust
montages that include film one and film
three it was extraordinary
we had a massive party that was all
themed around lordran so you could
literally walk into a lordran's party
with you know little
wooden kind of you know flagons of ale
and there was a hobbit band
there was a a hobbit bar wasn't an
oversized bar it was as if lord rings
had taken over that part of cannes i was
the same as you i thought this is a this
is a big swing i think at a time i
didn't really i would just like
you know
remember how drunk you were
we were in new zealand doing it and then
we were in canada it didn't seem but
looking back now yeah i mean what who
made that decision and what was the idea
and and what was it like as a producer
it being can that that because the
energy was insane it was great i mean
there was there was a prelude to the
moment
earlier
we had brought newline had brought some
of the key overseas distributors of the
movie down to wellington
to sort of see things and see some
footage and everyone was very nervous
because all we had was
dramatic scenes there was no visual
effects scenes no action scenes
and everyone's like we're really going
to show this to be like people are going
to get the wrong impression even though
they've read the script
and we showed the footage and people
were blown away they were by the quality
of the acting and the writing
direction
and someone who showered my name was one
of our partners
offered to buy
just buy half the movie right there wow
and i thought for sure oh well we're
definitely going to do that because
isn't it high risk and of course and bob
shea said no and i remember asking him
later like
why
why
he says you don't sell 50 of something
you know that's going to be great even
if it's like risky you only sell 50 of
something you don't think is gonna work
okay i'm like smart businessman
no one has a business like yours with
all its strengths and challenges to
succeed you need a hiring partner that
adapts to your needs
and that is
indeed
if you're hiring you need indeed because
indeed is the hiring partner where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place and indeed is the only job
site where you're guaranteed to find
quality applications that meet your
must-have requirements or else you don't
pay instead of spending hours on
multiple job sites hoping to find
candidates with the right skills you
need one powerful hiring partner that
can help you do it all indeed partners
with you on every step of the hiring
process find great talent through
time-saving tools like indeed instant
match assessments and virtual interviews
with instant match as soon as you
sponsor a post you get a short list of
quality candidates with resumes on
indeed that match your job description
and you can invite them to apply right
away plus
you only pay for quality applications
that meet your must-have requirements
that's right one of the things that i
really like about indeed is everything
is put in one particular spot right you
don't have to have all these pages open
and maybe you get a little bit
overwhelmed about looking for a
reference here or looking for something
else about hiring someone it's all in
one it's all in one place william lovely
stuff dom
no indeed knows that finding the right
skills makes all the difference that's
why you only pay for applications from
quality candidates that meet your
must-have requirements start hiring
right away with a 75 sponsored job
credit to upgrade your job post at
indeed.com
onion offer valid through april 30th go
to indeed.com to claim your 75 credit
before april 30th indeed.com slash onion
terms and conditions apply need to hire
you need indeed
now we're all trying to eat better but a
healthy breakfast doesn't have to be a
boring breakfast
true magic spoon has all the amazing
flavors that you love but without all
the bad stuff and it's amazing as a
midnight snack right before bed that's
true here i'll give you a few stats here
go on zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and only four net grams of
carb in each serving only 140 calories a
serving is keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and you can
build your own box available flavors to
build your own custom bundle our cocoa
fruited my favorite frosted mmm peanut
butter cookies and cream maple waffle
blueberry cinnamon plus the newly
reformulated honey nut flavor that will
now be added to the magic spoon's
permanent collection well it's about
time it was permanent very tight it's
one of my favorites i love that that
honey nut fantastic and tell you when
it's great as well after the gym
so you know what i was saying it's great
as a snack right before bed also right
after the gym because it's got a lot of
protein you see yeah that's true so go
to magicspoon.com to grab a custom
bundle of cereal and be sure to use our
promo code onion at the checkout to save
five dollars off your order and magic
spoon is so confident in their product
it's back with 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com onion and use the code
onion to save five dollars off thank you
magic spoon for sponsoring this episode
so cut to
pre-can
no one we're in new zealand no one knows
anything about these movies it's
pre-internet and in the vacuum of not
knowing people are just speculating
people and people just speculating like
oh
willow like all the
you know people just saying fantasy as a
genre whatever they want to say and it
annoyed peter it annoyed shay
and we thought how can we
shift the narrative and we'd had this
screening for this handful of buyers of
the drama scenes and so the thought was
why don't we go and recreate that but
add
like robust ad action and like really
serve a meal
so that was the thought
crystallized around moria relatively
quickly we put that together and then we
thought well if we're going to do that
when we have to do world media
all the distributors throw a giant party
we have to literally treat it like it's
a premiere right even though it's not
the whole movie right and it was
extremely exciting but very stressful
because it's literally like pointing
like i'm gonna hit the ball there right
and if you don't hit the ball there then
people say well why did you do this
if you were not gonna deliver why on
earth did you do that right so even
though we were all confident it was
really it was scary and i remember we
showed the footage at the olympia
theater yeah in can along uh that back
road um
and i remember after
afterwards like i was in the projection
room i actually wept
with joy and probably relief that it was
going and our i remember also our french
distributor sami hadidah who has passed
away but he was a big barrel chested guy
and obviously he bet his whole company
on these movies work he's literally
picked me up like like out of a looney
tunes cartoon he picked me up he's not
hard to do and literally kissed me on
the mouth like a big french like
like that and he was smiling so big
like his face would crack apart yeah and
i realized right then okay
it is an extraordinary sequence i mean
it's like i i
often talk about that that more a moment
with
comparing it to
the lobby scene in the matrix you know
the lobby scene in the matrix where you
know
he asks for guns and they get all the
rows of guns and then they walk into the
lobby and the security guard says please
remove all metal articles and you
realize that keanu and carry on moss are
just full of guns and then you get that
you know it's like a two-minute sequence
of just like
you know
shooting in slow motion in acrobatics
and if i were ever to try and introduce
someone to the matrix and they weren't
sure i would say okay let's watch this
two or three minutes that is the trilogy
encapsulated if you don't like that yeah
it's probably not for you
the moria thing
once they get into the tomb
and gimli realizes that these are his
kind of fallen brethren
and then sean bean delivers that amazing
you know line of they have a cave troll
and it's the first time that the the
fellowship really cements in that kind
of dungeons and dragons
of like we're gonna fight you've seen
legolas do some stuff you've seen aragon
do some stuff but you've not seen us as
a crew and even the hobbits are like
let's do it even though we can't do
anything yeah and then their cave troll
comes in which is at the time and even
now is is one of the most awe-inspiring
special effects you just which by the
way was a huge tennis a huge pole with a
tennis ball on the end of it yeah we we
felt terrified for a long time didn't we
yeah
um
and then you've got the run out
is it the goblins coming down the
pillars or are they that's yeah once
yeah after the the batter's battle's
over they're running towards elf then
yeah goblins coming down and you and as
an audience member you think oh okay
that was hectic and then
uh gandalf announces that there's a
balrog
and then you shall not pass and then we
all get spilled out that was the first
time i'd ever seen it in cannes and i
remember thinking
even even outside of me being involved
in it in a minor way i remember thinking
that's one of the greatest things i've
ever seen yeah
my little nephew saw
the first lord rings uh the fellowship
of the ring about three weeks ago
and i said to him what did you think of
the cave troll and the balrog and he
really liked the cave troll but even now
he was like the balrog was a little
scary you know it still scares people
nowadays and that special effect is what
20 years old it is and that was an early
effect with
fire like using fire in that way i only
noticed from the weta people not from
myself that the use of fire in that way
was not something that people were doing
like that was a relatively new
innovation so it was like high risk i
remember
at what a digital something called the
render wall which was this giant bank it
was like a it was like twice the size of
this room with just rendering compute
blinking computers
like uh which was all the things when
you put the balrog shots in they had to
render themselves into shape and it
would take like a day
and i would walk in and say is the
balrog in there right now
they're right now
and they say yeah he's in there he's
gonna be in there for like a month
because of those
you know and you're like it's amazing
and i remember i was with you i have a
distinct memory of being with you when
we were asked by one of our lovely ads
to head to the maurya set for the first
time
and the hobbits used to have to wear
these protective boots up to their knees
to protect their hobbit feet
and the four of us had these protective
boots and you and i were just kind of
talking and chatting away about nothing
in particular not knowing not really
expecting anything you know that
impressive to be happening at least i
wasn't and then you turn this corner and
walk into this
room with
cobwebs and skeletons with arrows in
their skulls or in their rib cage and
you know dust everywhere and and fallen
rocks and i remember
the energy of pete that day being so
giddy yeah yeah and i was saying oh pete
this is incredible pete with his little
giggle he's great it's great and all the
carvings and the walls things that you
would never see and it was all there it
was amazing well the the great the crack
uh
the crap tomb with all of this uh
dwarvish on that if you if you were able
to read dwarvish it would all make sense
and stuff yeah this is all lovely
tolkien stuff you're talking about here
but no which makes me want to go way
back mark and say how did you get
introduced to lord of the rings when you
i think you said 13 yeah how did you
find it it was because of dungeon
dragons there was um
there was a a coveted dungeon dragons
game among my
little middle school friends and um
where is this where they're here in los
angeles oh and los angeles and um there
was sort of a sort of required reading
list
for the game and uh brilliant yeah and
on top i actually read them out of order
because i didn't realize there was a
hobbit book that
that preceded it so i read lord of the
rings first not really it was a box of
books so i didn't i just sort of grabbed
whatever was on top
i did the same i thought you meant you
read it out of order in terms of you
read two towers first and then return
the king and then fellowship but i did
the same i read lord the rings first and
then went back and like the the first
time i read the hobbit was in new
zealand that that kind of slightly
bigger picture book version of the
hobbit which includes all the text but
it has some beautiful allen lee drawings
alongside it had i had read that
um i always say to people
in terms of an immersive experience i
think that you can't beat lord i agree
being thrown into a world
so completely and so entranced by middle
earth just yeah you can't be there when
i was young and i've told this story
before we we read the hobbit as friends
and we didn't really read books together
but we we read the hobbit for some
reason and when i tried to read lord the
rings and it wasn't bilbo as the
protagonist i just couldn't read that i
was like i want more bilbo baggins you
know and uh so i didn't read loader
rings until just before the films wow
yeah and i love them yeah they are
incredible books
so um principal photography ends mark
and you have
all of this footage which is then
getting put together
is
with you chatting consistency
consistently with p
and obviously
um
being at new line
when did this kind of ground swell start
of like oh we've we've actually got
something here this is starting to
deliver i mean the can
screen obviously was like the total
affirmation that we had something we all
thought we had something but that was
like the outside validation of it
i always had the faith of like a true
believer so i didn't have any doubt
about it
but
you know for people
for other people like we never test
screened the movies we didn't have like
test screenings and things like that we
would sometimes bring
i'd sometimes fly back with videotapes
of of early cuts and show them to a
small group of new liners and just for
like clean viewing and i would just take
notes and fly back to share them with
peter and fran right that was it um
because yeah because obviously the
film's in the early going you know films
always start long and then they whittle
themselves into shape yeah so yes so the
the canned screening was when it was
clear
do you remember watching the um we would
go to a new line to watch the movie
sometimes
that was that was always an amazing day
yeah it would be an afternoon and we'd
be waiting outside like
very overwhelming yeah just straight and
because you would always have you were
allowed to bring a couple of guests
maybe an agent so you're trying to make
them feel but you're also thinking god
what's this going to be like yeah no for
sure i remember obviously back then
elijah was still quite a heavy smoker he
doesn't smoke anymore i'd never been a
habitual smoker at all but i remember
leaving it must have been fellowship
with you and elijah and a few other
people and elijah went to smoke a
cigarette and i said can i have one of
those cigarettes enlargement yeah and i
remember just thinking i don't know why
i need a cigarette or if it's even going
to help but my the level of nervous
energy yeah having watched fellowship is
so overwhelming so so obviously there's
a there's a very
considerate
path in terms of okay we've got
something we're gonna we're gonna take
it to can we're gonna we're gonna do
quite a big like
welcome to our movie
once it starts to pick up this
groundswell of interest post can
what else do you do towards the lead-up
of fellowship to help turn this into the
must-watch kind of christmas release
it's funny it's counter-intuitive
everyone decided to go quiet because can
had been such a roar
that the feeling was it's only may the
film's not coming out until december
17th
so
let's just go silent
and then bring it back up again later
because otherwise we felt it would be
too much we'd just be numb if we just
kept pounding the drum
so that's what we actually did which
seemed
seemed really smart now but the time is
nerve-wracking because you're kind of
like no no no let's keep it going fan
the fame but it was true may to december
is a lifetime i don't remember but did
did
did lord rings do anything like closer
to the release did they do like a
time magazine article or a live
i know we did vanity fair but that was
during principal photography yeah there
was a whole bunch of stuff and now but
now i'm my memory is challenged to
remember what it was yeah i wonder
because there was that incredible single
image of elijah frodo holding the ring
and the glow of the ring kind of
lighting his face almost in a kind of
rembrandt type homage right that was one
of the first pieces of kia that i
remember thinking oh perfect so classy
you've got the gold kind of fun of lord
the rings and just this image of frodo
looking extremely overwhelmed by this
ring in his hand
chef's kiss
absolutely lovely tom
billy and dom eat the world
guys we're back
in my particular favorite section of the
show
billy and dom
eat the world because i like to have
guilt-free snacks and in a situation
like this it's like just have to eat
what the guest brings and the the
calories don't count it's like drinking
on a plane they don't count on a plane
either
marco you you've always been one of the
more generous people that i've been
lucky enough to know in my life because
every single time we
have gone to eat you've also you've
always said this is on me and you have
that iconic line of the talent never
pays right which i used to love yes
saying to billy before you got here
which still makes me cringe to this day
but it happened i remember
ozil being in london yep we went to nobu
with you yes elijah orlando i think
billy was there i was there a few other
people it was kind of a table of 10 or
12 something like that
and about halfway through dinner you
said guys this is on me and i remember
thinking
that is a heck of a bill and you said no
no that's how it works that's how this
is how it works it was an amazing night
but we're going to go back here and talk
about one of the things that you
introduced into my life which is mochi
billy i absolutely love mochi yeah
i really are really it's and this is
mochi ice cream we're having isn't it
yes the texture is extremely moorish so
so what's been your story with mochi so
the truth is the first time
and i think the last time i had mochi
ice cream was
with you
and the reason i nominated for this and
i actually brought a little artifact to
connect it so
in my pocket i have a receipt from a
dinner
that we had unfortunately you weren't
there
but it is from november of
november of
2001.
[Music]
and basically i didn't keep
no no here's why so basically we had
this great dinner it was you elijah
orlando me orlando's friend sebastian
yeah sebastian's cousin yeah was it here
and here in l.a hannah
came with elijah right and then someone
whose name i don't recognize but anyway
i can say it i remember calling them
japanese gummy bears you did you call
them chinese gummy bears chinese coming
back so basically we went and we did
this thing and we we just shown the
movie not in its final form and it's
nearly final form we were all in a big
high yeah so we all went down to this
restaurant ubon and had like an insane
meal like the kind you're just
describing
and i said
meals on me and everyone's like no i
said yes i insist talent never pays
and then orlando said you know mark's
like the tenth member of the fellowship
which he then wrote mark you are the
tenth member of the fellowship thanks
for more than dinner orly and then you
wrote marky thanks for the chinese gummy
bears till next time dom wow and down at
the bottom is mochi ice cream mochi
can i have a look yeah it's for you look
oh man that is brilliant that's an
amazing answer
my gosh it wasn't a cheap meal either it
happened just organically people started
grabbing no i'll sign it i'll write it
that's great wow that is brilliant now
who was the person that you couldn't
there's elijah there's hannah
and you are the 10th member
that's right you have thanks to you guys
as number 10. you have the uh
number 10 tattoo thanks to you all wow
elijah said hey mark thanks for such a
brilliant memorable dinner and the first
night of the first cast screening so you
must have been in scotland yeah must
have been missed that one
so we've got sebastian here and then
we've got there's something some little
scribble
mark your commitment to the film is
infectious the food was as well thank
you for both sebastian i don't know who
that
i don't know who the other person is
either
yeah yeah i mean that's amazing that you
kept that just as a little artifact mark
at the time i've had a little box which
i put like i have the tickets from the
return of the king oscar
ceremony right right so we had mochi and
so i thought i would nominate these
breaks i love the mochi i remember this
night because i remember having not had
it and you you insisted oh we have to
have mochi and i tried it and i was like
oh this consistency is incredible and we
ordered quite a few of them i'll read a
little blurb here mochi's japanese cake
sweet made from pounding
uh glutinous rice which you said yeah i
was right into a sticky paste and
molding it into shape mochi can then be
prepared in many ways mochi ice cream
being one of the most recently
implemented ideas most popularly
the mochi includes a sweet filling
inside such as anko which is red bean
paste to make a japanese confectionary
wagashi called daifuku
amazing i love look at the end of this
is one mochi ice cream one mochi ice
cream one mochi ice cream two mochi ice
creams one mochi ice cream two mochi ice
creams you must have just been like one
of them no because we were all totally
high on like the screening yeah there
was no way we weren't gonna go crazy
yeah yeah amazing
you must have too much ice cream seeds
well let's try it now now there's a it
looks like there's a green tea and what
would the strawberry
i think we've been told strawberry we're
getting that we're getting confirmation
we have a strawberry can have a
strawberry
we go and this one's green tea there you
go
now just talk to us about the talent
never pays mark that's a producerial
kind of golden rule because it's it
was that just a youth thing i think it's
both when in my very very short brief
window when i was a writer and not yet a
would-be producer executive
that tends to my producer took me to
lunch when i when i got my little
development deal and you took me to
lunch
which one was the double green tea since
it's right there
it's almost melted
um
and we went to lunch and he um
i was gonna i got my wallet out to pay
or to split i think i was gonna split
and um he said no no no
talent never pays
that was it hold on
[Music]
like it's really good we were right to
be excited
oh my god
well
well let me give you some more facts
how far did you get down dom i only did
the first one this is this is really
seriously good
i forgot that it was this good now how
come you you've not eaten it for such a
long time ma because i just wasn't
rolling with people that were mochi
people
emoji people
brilliant now mochi is part of a
japanese tradition during the new year
yeah well there's a tradition
a traditional ceremony called mochisuke
in which people use a traditional mortar
to hold the sticky rice and they'll take
alternate using a giant wooden mallet
to pound the rice an emoji during the
new year a certain kind of mochi
called kagame mochi is also made as a
traditional decoration placed in
household
shinto
altars kagami mochi consists of two
round mochi cakes stacked atop of each
other which has been said to symbolize
various things including the coming and
going of years
yin and yang the moon and sun regardless
mochi is indeed not just a sweet but a
traditional food relevant to japanese
culture
i think the first time i went to japan
was with you mark no couldn't i think i
had that been yet oh in that case cancel
that it was with you give us give us
that the green i think you went to japan
the year before me as well i went well i
can't believe you've never been with all
that success i know it's bad oh by the
way i did all these movies with
wonderful jackie chan who invited me to
china multiple times or to hong kong
back then and uh
and of course then my parents go to hong
kong for part of a vacation and jackie
chan sends like a limousine
and an assistant takes them to all these
amazing places that no tourists would
ever think to go and they come back and
say jackie chan is the best person in
the universe and i'm like i know
i know are you still in correspondence
with him i'm still in touch with him
yeah so what does he what are you right
now i hope people are realizing
as i started this conversation with is
that you are
one of the most
important pieces of the lord of rings
jigsaw right absolutely mark and i think
everyone knows that or they should know
that and on top of that
uh the jackie chan thing you were
instrumental in getting jackie chan uh
to to america is that right yeah he'd
he'd been to america before
a decade before and had made some films
with some
that didn't reflect his what he felt was
his spirit creativity creativity then he
went back to make hong kong films and
when he made this film rumble in the
bronx and it's similar
it's similar going back to your question
about how to do what you do like if
you're fortunate enough to have a
platform
and your platform is with bob shea say
i knew that bob shea had regretted that
earlier in his corporate life he had
wanted to be
wanted to distribute the films of bruce
lee and he lost out to another company
competitively couldn't do it wow lost
out missed opportunity
i saw this film i thought
and i'd been a big jackie chan fan
anyway
and i had said you know bob this is a
chance
to this is a chance to do
a new thing like with a new artist and
this would be even better
um and
he backed me on that and we then we
ended up acquiring three films three of
his hong kong films and as importantly
that's why we made the rush hour
franchise not me but new line yeah the
rush hour so that turned to a huge huge
deal
do you want a strawberry one no i've had
enough i've had enough john would it be
possible to put these in the freezer are
you wanting them for leah well i just
think that they're on the turn they're
absolutely delicious we give them marks
we mark things in three ways mark mm-hmm
um
the flavor of course the aesthetics how
it looks and how useful is it as a food
i gotcha which is a strange category but
we enjoy it john
delicious
where were they from
get them in the freezer would you john
lovely
the taste totally delicious i'm a big
fan of green tea i have of my morning
ritual in the morning in the morning
obviously my morning ritual
is to uh have a matcha
green tea okay in the little traditional
japanese
um
cup with a little whisk
and you stir it around in some cold
water and get it all
mixed in and kind of frothy and then you
fill it up with hot water not boiling
water because if you put boiling water
on green tea it makes it bitter
so that taste of the green tea mochi
is probably my favorite out of the two
wow do you like the strawberry or the
green tea i think
i like both but i think because i had
the strawberry first
i i think i enjoyed that one more okay
but i love both of them did you know
that um putting ice cream in it is a
that was a sort of american invention it
says here yeah
around 1981 when the korean company
lotte began selling the suite as a
special type of snow viewing daifuku
anyway they basically said it's better
with ice cream
well everything is is that true yeah
um do you have a favorite out of the
green tea or the strawberry i like
i like the green tea ones a little bit
more of a delicate flavor i'm gonna give
the green tea one
an eight point two out of ten
it was great flavor tom i'm going to
give it a 9.2
i'll love them mark
you can use a decimal point if you want
oh then i'll go with the nine point five
oh what's up yeah for the green tea
aesthetics i mean i like the cold cold
coldness and there's ice cream inside
but it won't melt because it's
surrounded by the most sticky rice yeah
so sticky and nice it's a ten for me a
ten ten i love the way it could not look
any better i loved it
loved it i'll give it a name
i'm going with 10 cause form and
function
exactly wow you could put it in your
pocket and it wouldn't melt well i don't
know about that
usefulness how useful can you make a pie
from it
i don't know
can you deserve
what else would you do with that oh
you're talking about mochi are you
talking about mochi ice cream
ice cream
i bet you could do a mochi ice cream
cake right you must be able but using
the mochi because mochi i'll give you
that that is
because i see pinkberry right they put
mochi you can ask them for mochi okay
you said it's an under there sometimes
it's not on the thing you can't say it
and you say have you got mochi they go
and it's underneath they make that noise
but one time i was getting it and the
guy who was serving looked like a
bodybuilder you know and he says do you
know how many calories are in that i was
like
and the mochi he says one scoop is like
200 calories
and he put me off it
because it was tasty but
i went to a restaurant last week i'm
slightly digressing here but i just need
to say this we won't mention the
restaurant okay i went to a restaurant
last week
the waiter put my plate down on the
table
and then noticed there was a hair
on the plate hey and just put the plate
down and went
sorry about that and just walked away
and i thought maybe take the plate away
yeah and do a little
don't
and don't show me that there was a hair
on my plate and then just say and i'm
going to leave you to that how many
calories are under here it wouldn't be
much not much yeah no ah usefulness
you could make a cake out of it but it's
not a huge amount
i mean it's useful as in its taste and
and look but other than that you're not
going to say oh get me the much ice
cream i'm going to use it for something
i'm going to give it a 2. yeah well you
i've got i'm going to be more generous
and give it a 3.5
i'll split the difference at 3. there
you go um in all the times that you've
taken cast members for dinner and stuff
like that mark is there a particular
one that stood out in terms of when you
got the check and you thought my
goodness
the heck of a night that i've enjoyed
i mean that that one that nobu night in
london i remember even for me i thought
yeah that is the nightmare because i
personally at that point could not have
afforded to pay for that right and you
were like guys no problem and i thought
i hope i hope that's something that new
line is paying and not mark
um
but has there been have you have you
bought dinner for 30 people 40 people
before i bought i bought i bought dinner
for 20 or 30 people yeah
i mean here's the thing when i was
working at the studio
i was very
blessed that i had
a you know a corporate credit card which
i could use as long as i used it
responsibly
in the right set of circumstances so i
didn't have to do it but even now when i
have my own company
court five like i still believe talent
never pays because the thing is
without
the artists and the material
there is nothing
and for me and it's maybe a very old
school of me but what producing is is
basically taking
artisan material
and bringing
money and distribution into orbit like
the four food groups
those without those four things you
can't have three you gotta have four
and
but you can't even do the second two
without the first two
so and not everyone can do it so if
you're fortunate enough to be blessed
with skills which you then through craft
develop improve
you know so on that's like a that's kind
of like a miracle so i just don't think
i just think that uh yeah talent doesn't
pay hmm well that's a lovely thing to
hear matt and i love i love that idea
that that's how films are made and uh
and i know we're going to look forward
to see many more films from you yeah in
the future we can't wait i'm going to be
at wondercon uh in next month april
because our tv show on disney plus the
quest is going to have a panel there oh
yeah right everyone should go along to
that please absolutely well let's talk a
little bit about court five yeah so so
um
how long's that company been going and
you know what's the kind of signature
behind that particular company because
that's all you isn't it sure it's myself
and jane fleming who is another former
new liner with whom my partner has been
at the company for about 10 years it's a
classic independent production company
we do film and television
um
opportunistically it's not affiliated
with it with a studio or a streamer it
just stands by itself
and
we basically
find artists and talent you know that we
can get behind and work with them to try
to make
content happen that's literally what we
do it says i know it sounds kind of like
very straightforward but that's really
what the game is i never tire of it
people often ask
with lord of the rings like you know
some people not so nicely but um you
know do you worry that you peaked too
soon
and what
the ignorance under that question is
like if you're doing it because of the
craft and because you like making things
if you're a maker
then sometimes you're going to make
something gigantic and sometimes you're
going to make something smaller things
in between it doesn't really matter what
order they come in you can't really
control it i often i often relate
particularly to actors for that reason
because it roles you know different
kinds of things big roles small roles or
a substantial role in a big thing versus
a smaller thing and i find that that's
when you look at the careers
of really interesting actors you find
this great variety mm-hmm inevitably
yeah yeah and i mean lord the rings was
such a
such a monster in so many different ways
i remember pete saying to us
you know several times that he would
never make anything as big and huge and
uh you know life-changing as lord of the
rings and obviously he's going on to do
some extraordinary things um
but the quest so the quest has big ties
towards your love of dungeons and
dragons yeah
it's really simple we we've made it for
disney plus and basically we've taken
eight real teenagers middle schoolers
and we even dropped them into a fully
immersive 360 degree fantasy world
called ever realm
where they are
prophesied heroes
inside a narrative that is unfolding
so we make it with uh with our partners
are the folks that make the amazing race
and who make queer eye and legendary on
hbo max and basically
it's a show where kids come and try to
save a kingdom but there's scripted
characters inside this kingdom and how
the kids behave change the story but
there is a story unfolding through the
whole thing so it's this lovely hybrid
immersive television experiment which
disney plus has completely backed to the
hilt and it's really exciting brilliant
have you finished it no we finished it
so we have so wondercon is the is the
kickoff of our
sort of you know publicity outreach
brilliant wondercon yeah great the quest
[Music]
we do have a section
in our show called funky for you where
we ask a guest to
bring in a song that
makes the
feet tap a little bit yeah you have a
story behind yes this song do you want
to tell us or should i read it sure i'll
tell it to you it actually is inspired
by your
your your your episode with elijah
because i too was brought taken by
elijah to real groovy elijah has like a
first of all
i was very sad in my musical taste very
limited maybe in my musical tastes right
and when elijah found out that was the
case because he is so robust and uh has
such a comp missionary complex about
music
he said all right
we're going
i'm gonna find we're going just come so
we went to real groovy he asked me all a
bunch of questions about things i liked
he made bunches of like
i was embarrassed i didn't i didn't have
any like radiohead like he introduced me
to like things it's really embarrassing
right right but basically he turned me
onto a bunch of stuff and then i started
going back there on my own and making my
own selections and one of the first
selections i dared make by myself
was
dj shadow amazing artist and we're going
to listen to a song by dj shadow called
midnight in a perfect world
[Music]
think about it
[Music]
and understand
[Music]
love dj shadow i think that song also
features in one of my all-time favorite
documentaries which is dark days have
you seen dance i have not but i know
about that yeah yeah black and white
documentary about the people living in
the new york subway system never seen it
oh it's extraordinary and dj shadow does
all the music for that and that song
features in it heavily because at some
point in that song that song goes no
approaching midnight yes yes yes it's a
great song um
and just to touch upon real groovy
records for a second most
sundays because we work saturdays didn't
we sometimes yeah yeah
most sundays
the boys which would be kind of myself
billy elijah and orlando and then
other people would come into that group
if they were around
would find themselves after having
breakfast at fidel's or maybe eva dixons
we would all
head over to real groovy records which
was just a staple of
wellington town centre at the very end
of cuba street a big record shop right
yeah it was big
full of beautiful people
all kind of struggling from the
the night out on on saturday night and
uh
i mean i dread to think how much money
we spent in all well
per diem went into that
music show
hundreds of cds yeah yeah um and when
you think about it now most things like
you you pay for whatever streaming
platform and you can get most music now
but there's something wonderful about
ganina store as you say maybe with
someone who's passionate about some type
of music and introducing you and taking
that home and playing it yeah i remember
so much i mean there's a there's so many
different records or albums that i got
out of real real groovy but one of the
ones that stands out because it's still
a formative album in my life now
and i don't know why i bought it because
it wasn't kind of being talked about or
whispered about but i was in real groovy
on my own i think it was in the middle
of the week
the other boys were working on set i
went to real groovy and i bought the
debut album by a band called cigaros
this icelandic band okay kind of
talked about as kind of the icelandic
radiohead
big expansive kind of epic songs they
actually supported radiohead at the
hollywood bowl which i went to which was
incredible the front cover is this
like alien fetus
and
i bought a few other things but then i
was like oh that looks interesting and i
bought it and
didn't know anything about the bend put
it on and it's one of the few moments in
my life i had it with leonard cohen i
had it with paul simon
where i thought i've heard this before
and i hadn't right it's almost as if it
like sunk into my brain in some strange
collective
consciousness thing and it's one of the
real
standout moments in music discovery for
me
wow it was just happenstance you know so
thanks real groovy are they still around
real groovy i don't think they are i
think they're in auckland i don't know
if they're in wellington ah so sad and
you were talking about eva dixon's yeah
the cafe i accidentally went there the
last day that it was serving right i
don't know if it's moved or anything but
i i was in wellington uh and i thought
i'm gonna go to eva dixon's and there
was a sign up final day yeah so i had
breakfast and that was that they're gone
now that's a [ __ ] oh i don't i don't
want to stop it in the donor no no well
mark it's been brilliant to have you um
is it funky so we we ready
rate this funkiness based on a level of
funk
based on um is it brahms brahms has no
fun zero level of funk to prince
and incredibly funky
yeah his most purple is the most funky
you can get
and i would mark that because it's a dj
and it is very funky and i like the drum
sound i love drum sounds when it sounds
all roomy
i'm going to give that a dj funk
level of funk well i mean that is funky
well it's even in the name
i'm going to give that a level of funk
based on
early wu-tang clan funk which is oh
we're just getting as heck again funky
what about you mark i don't even have
the language to rate it oh well
well here's a few examples of people at
the high level of funk maybe stevie
wonder would be a high level of flunk
sly in the family stone very fantastic
bobby womack tina turner oh if you don't
think they're funky you could say um
strauss
i would say strauss is funky you find
strands quite very funky um it's just
it's just you don't have to mark that
but thank you very much for breaking
brilliant music thank you this has been
so great hanging with you guys oh it's
amazing and i'm sure people out there
watching or listening to the show will
be fascinated to find out your journey
from a slightly different angle of those
trilogies obviously they've heard us
bang on about what it meant to be
on set but for you having to
be one of the major players solving
these very sophisticated problems on a
day-by-day basis i'm sure people are
fascinated
the tenth member of the fellowship yeah
you know you got a tattoo just to finish
on that tattoo yes let's have a look
to you guys it was it was yourself and
pete and was there someone else god
that's richard taylor and barry osborne
amazing hold on we all go
yours is a nine yours is the ten hours
of nine so it kind of has some mirroring
yeah absolutely it's so brilliant
great place to put it no fantastic
mark it's been great to have you on
wait how do people get in touch with us
you can get in touch with us at the
friendship onion at cassmedia.com or you
can leave a message at speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion and
don't forget to watch the quest on
disney plus when does it start they're
going to announce it at wondercon
announced the wonder car brilliant uh
please leave all your messages on our
youtube channel and send us your tongue
twisters and send us songs that you
either purposefully or accidentally sing
wrong
and
say anything else billy gifts because he
loves i love gifts we'll see you next
week see you next week thank you mark
bye bye-bye
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl
[Music]